we knew that it was finally released
after being kept hidden from the public
for months that the Schumer McConnell
border insecurity bill would be bad but
even we didn't realize how bad now just
last week we he was assuring critics
including the angle that what was leaked
out about the bill were just internet
rumors including that the bill would
permit up to 5,000 migrants per day into
the country then Senator l for said this
this Authority is a 5,000 authority to
say if you get to 5,000 which we've been
there every single day except for seven
in the last 4 months that it completely
closes the Border
down wait wait wait wait wait I thought
that the 5,000 migrants can come in
welcome that that trigger was just an
internet rumor I mean how long ago did
we do that on the angle two two weeks
ago three weeks ago well in the first
place given the damage and strain Biden
has already inflicted on all of you in
America with the millions of migrants
that have been allowed in we shouldn't
be allowing even one migrant into the
country let alone 5,000 encounters a day
it's a joke second just so everyone
understands this under this supposedly
tough as Nails legislation the border is
never closed even if you do think
mayorcas could ever be trusted to
oversee things and track the numbers now
you don't need to take my word for it
because that's EX ly what one of the
architects of the bill Senator Chris
Murphy said the president and the border
patrols still retain broad discretionary
powers to wave people in including
thousands at a time and unaccompanied
miners don't even count toward that
5,000 threshold number so the entire
bill is a travesty and if lenford hadn't
just been reelected in 2022 he never
would be championing it I promise you
that here are some of the key reasons to
hate the bill from Red State and lawyers
at America First legal first all migrant
families must be released from custody
second only single individuals can be
deported third emergency Powers don't
affect ports of Entry that still get
this must allow a minimum a minimum of
1,400 Mig migrants a day now there are
30 ports of entry in the United States
that equals 42,000 migrants a month or
wait for it 504,000 migrants a year now
the emergency can be ignored if the
president decides it's not in our
national
interest the Biden team retains power to
opt out of all limits on migrant numbers
because there are broad humanitarian
exceptions mayorcas has unilateral
authority to Grant final Asylum for
individuals which equals a rapid path to
citizenship a lot of Americans don't
understand that but when you get Asylum
that's a path to citizenship and there's
a broad exception to emergency
Provisions again that everyone's touting
today based on the quote totality of
circumstances test that's broad enough
to drive a truck through and anyone who
claims that fear of persecution or
torture and they're just reading it from
a laminated card when they cross the
border is not deported but again instead
they go through an arduous
administrative process okay so they'll
be tied in that for a while and this
also codifies the controversial Biden
rule that allows these far-left Asylum
officers not immigration judges to rule
on individual Asylum claims oh just for
good measure it gives them a 15% raise
as well it also includes $1.4 billion
directed to providing shelters and
Immigration Services 36 million to hire
lawyers for some illegals finally
there's the automatic conditional
permanent resident status for migrants
who entered after July
2021 in other words this is a grab bag
of goodies for the open borders caucus
for every provision that sounds like
enforcement there's a way around it
during the
implementation but wait a second Laura
this is a real compromise I heard this
all day long that's all coming from the
uni party you know I say to that where's
the compromise exactly because they get
60 billion dollar that they've wanted
for Ukraine everything that they wanted
but conservatives that have cared about
the border for years decades they get a
bill that gives them nothing that they
wanted on the border and in fact it
would tie president Trump's hands if in
fact he wins in
November and all you need to know and I
saw this yesterday is that pro-amnesty
Connecticut Senator Chris Murphy is
thrilled about this legislation he
reassures the left that the emergency
power to to shut the border down is weak
tweeting that it has important checks on
that power it can only be used for a
limited number of days per year it
sunsets in three years emergency cases
that show up in between the ports still
need to be accepted the ports must
process as I said before a minimum of
1,400 claims meaning people a day let
that sink in again a minimum of 1,400 a
day at 30 point ports of
Entry people say well maybe Langford and
Schumer don't really know what's in the
bill or McConnell doesn't really know
what's in the bill he's just overseeing
they know exactly what they're doing
here they thought that they could drop
the text of this phony bill on Sunday
then as you've seen today start their
media blitz before they force a vote on
this on Wednesday and then they thought
that either squeak it through or that at
least help Biden and hurt Trump which is
a sh shared goal of 90% of the uni party
I am proud NE leader McConnell and I who
disagree on many issues have never
worked so closely together on
legislation as we did on this because we
both realize the gravity of the
situation and how important passage of
this legislation
is wait a second he Schumer now
understands the gravity of the situation
where has he been it almost sounds like
he's calling the order a crisis after
democrats for years denied it actually
attacked us for calling it a crisis now
in late 2022 after Millions had already
flooded America Schumer was not using
the word crisis and didn't sound upset
at all about the Border CR crossers in
fact for Schumer it was the opposite we
have a population that is not
reproducing it on its own with the same
level that it used to the only way we're
going to have a great future in America
is if we welcome and embrace immigrants
the dreamers and all of them cuz our
ultimate goal is to help the dreamers
but get a path to citizenship for all 11
million or however many undocumented
there are
here a path to citizenship is the goal
the key is they want the votes and
remember the the weasel words you heard
there my the the immigrants or however
many there are here now remember there
can never be enough migrants to make the
uni party happy which is why the
McConnell crew refused to work with
Seeker Johnson to pass hr2 which was
that house bill which actually is tough
and actually very clear on
enforcement so the bad faith on the part
of the Bill's Republican supporters is
so egregious that none of them should
ever work in politics again I know that
sounds harsh but it's the way it needs
to go this bill does not make the border
secure in fact it assures that the
Border remains open and massively
increas inrees number of visas and work
permits allotted for families of
illegals and current H1B Visa holders
now we think about what we need in the
country today we need more foreign
workers when wages are still not keeping
up with high costs and more companies
are announcing layoffs aren't
they if you want to understand why
Donald Trump Remains the dominating
force in American politics remember that
what you're seeing played out play out
in the Senate right now is what he's
always warned about the damage inflicted
when a bipartisan establishment is
unchecked and allowed a free hand to
plot against the interests and wishes of
the voters that must end with this bill
it's time to retire mcconell and
everyone who attempts to pet perpetuate
this fraud on the American public and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else